So now we have a safe way to
update our static assets.
But as we saw in the previous chapter,
the changes would be
in the waiting worker.
Ideally we want users to be on
the latest version as soon as possible.
We want them to get the latest features,
the latest design, and
of course bug fixes.
But as we saw when a new worker is
discovered it waits until all pages
using the current version go away,
before it can take over.
And, that could be a long time.
Let's do something better.
Our goal here is to tell user once
an update has been found, and
give them a button to ignore it or
refresh the page to get the new version.
But how can we achieve this?
Well, first off,
let's cover the update notification.
Thankfully there are APIs that give
us insight into the service work
of a lifecycle.
When you register for
a service worker it returns a promise.
That promise fulfills with a service
work a registration object.
This object has properties and
methods relating to the service
worker registration.
We get methods to do things like
unregister the service worker or
programatically trigger an update.
We also get free properties installing,
waiting, and active.
These will point to
a serviceWorker object or be null.
They give you an insight into
the serviceWorker life cycle.
They also map directly to the dev tools
view we've been working with so far.
This dev tools view is actually just
looking at these registration objects.
For example, if there's a serviceWorker
instance in .installing,
that tells us there's
an update on its way,
although it might be thrown
away if the install fails.
If there's a serviceWorker in .waiting,
we know there's an updated
serviceoWorker ready and
waiting to take over.
The registration object will emit
an event when a new update is found.
Called well, update found.
When this file's not installing
has become a new worker.
On the serviceWorker objects themselves,
you can look at their state.
The state can be installing
the installer that has fired, but
hasn't yet completed.
Installed, installation completed
successfully but hasn't yet activated.
Activating.
The activate event has fired but
not yet complete, or activated.
The serviceWorker is ready
to receive fetch events.
And also, there's redundant.
The serviceWorker has been thrown away.
Redundant happens when the serviceWorker
has been superseded by a newer
worker and it also happens if
the serviceWorker fails to install.
The serviceWorker fires an event.
State change.
Whenever the value of
the state property changes.
Also.
navigator.serviceWorker.controller
refers to the serviceWorker
that controls this page.
You want to tell user when
there's an update ready.
But because the serviceWorker
update happens in the background,
the update could be ready and
waiting, it could be in progress, or
it might not have started yet.
This means we need to look at the state
of things when the page loads.
But we may also need to listen for
future changes.
For instance, if there's no controller,
that means this page didn't
load using a serviceWorker.
So they loaded the content
from the network.
Otherwise we need to
look at the registration.
If there's a waiting worker there's
an update ready and waiting.
We tell the user about it.
Otherwise if there isn't installing
worker there's an update in progress.
Of course the update may fail.
So, we listen to the state
changes to track it and
if it reaches the installed state.
We tell the user.
Otherwise, we listen for
the update found event.
When that fires we track the state
of the installing worker and
if it reaches the installed
state we tell the user.
That's how we can tell
user about updates,
whether they're already there,
in progress, or start some time later.